In this portion of our course, we will go over some final recommendations.
I will provide you with some tips and resources for you to use as you continue your work in
training with metahumans.
We will first go over how to troubleshoot certain issues you may encounter.
Then we will take a look at how to import and assign body correctives that have been
authored using the PoseDriverConnect toolset.
And we will finish off by looking at some resources related to the topics discussed in this course.
So let's first go over some troubleshooting tips.
In this section, we will take a look at how to troubleshoot certain issues that you may
encounter at various stages of the workflows we covered.
We will go over how to handle issues with shaders, re-importing the head-LOD-FBX files,
and material conflicts.
We will also touch upon considerations when using the DNA calibration custom body workflow.
So let's begin with troubleshooting shader issues.
The images below show the preset Lina that was modified using the UnrealFest DNA calibration script.
When applying facial animations, you may encounter the shader issue she has on her upper eyelids.
To fix this, you can recompute the tangents for the green channel of the head shader.
Open up the face skeletal mesh, and in the asset details panel, locate the LOD0 sections.
Section 0 is the head shader.
Go to the recompute tangents dropdown and change it to green, and this will resolve the issue.
Let's take a look at another issue you may encounter when re-importing the head-LOD-FBX files.
Depending on the engine version you are using, you may encounter issues when using the re-import with new file option.
When re-importing the head-LOD-FBX file, using the re-import with new file option,
if the process of importing the file takes a very long time and nothing happens,
you can paste the interchange feature flags import-FBX command with the value of 0 into the command prompt,
and then select the re-import with new file again.
For engine versions 5.4 and earlier, in order for the FBX import option window to appear,
when re-importing with the new file, you will need to go to the editor preferences and search for re-import.
Then go to miscellaneous and enable show import dialog at re-import.
When you are importing the LOD0 head-FBX, you may see a conflict show up in the re-import content window.
A material conflict may occur if you have named the head geometry assets incorrectly.
Select reset to FBX to resolve the conflict.
Another conflict you may encounter is for unmatched skeleton joints.
This may occur if you use the export FBX script from the DNA calibration examples folder
to export a newer version of MetaHuman.
Make note of it and proceed.
Now let's go over some considerations when using the DNA calibration custom body workflow.
The current version of the custom body workflow does not update the lower head LOD additional assets.
The additional assets will not be scaled and translated with the head geometry asset.
If you are planning to use LOD0 only, this will be fine.
If you are going to need the lower LODs, consider using the AtomicSDNA calibration script
to scale and translate the DNA and then use the custom body workflow for aligning the skeletons.
Use the DNA file that is generated from the AtomicSDNA calibration workflow with the custom body workflow.
For step one, you will not have to do anything with the position and scaled mesh.
And for step two, you can use the LOD0 head mesh as the new neutral mesh
if the neck vertex positions have already been authored.
Now let's move on to the final section of our course
where we will go over how to import and assign body correctives to a MetaHuman character.